foreign
[Music]
parliament in the midst of a vote on
amendments to the election law
after a heated session that ran late on
Sunday night and into the early hours of
Monday it was finally passed the
legislation means provincial and
national government Representatives will
be chosen on the basis of proportional
representation
in our case it will preserve the rights
of the main components of Iraqi society
and prevent the instability created by
the multiple constituency system in the
last election
but opposition lawmakers say it favors
larger more established political
parties at the expense of emerging
blocks and independent MPS
protesters against the changes took
place in several provinces as well as in
the capital bardad
independent MPS and protesters say the
previous election law was one of the
major victories of their demonstrations
in 2019
they fear these amendments reverse that
gain and increase their political
repression
there are already calls for a boycott or
the dissolution of parliament
we declare we will be boycotting the
elections and will not take pass in any
proceedings related to the amended law
if tensions escalate as they have in the
past Iraq could be on the verge of
another prolonged politically standoff
a very possible scenario is the return
of the 2019 protest this time with the
saddest movement making a second
comeback alongside the opposition if
that happens we may see another
political Deadlock
putting iraqi's hopes for political and
economic reform even further Out Of
Reach
foreign